all right in the last video we talked
about the election of 1824 which turned
into a grudge match between John Quincy
Adams and Andrew Jackson in which Andrew
Jackson won the popular vote but John
Quincy Adams won the electoral vote and
the tiebreaker turned out to be Speaker
of a house Henry Clay who helped give
the election to Adams but then was
shortly named Secretary of State by
Adams leading Andrew Jackson and his
partisans to claim that a corrupt
bargain
had taken place and this really shows
how the nature of American politics had
changed because this sort of you scratch
my back I'll scratch yours was common
practice in American politics between a
few elite men who were generally in
charge of the political process but
Andrew Jackson and his supporters say
that this is undemocratic this is the
kind of elitist hokum that we do not
need in our nation of free white men so
four years later in the election of 1828
it is a Jackson John Quincy Adams
rematch and the gloves are off so in the
first video in this series I mentioned
that during this time period a lot of
the aspects that we consider part of
American politics first came to the fore
and one of the things that you'll see in
the election of 1828 really for the
first time is down and dirty mudslinging
or making angry attacks ad hominem or at
the man rather than at his principles
attacks on your opponent so Andrew
Jackson probably already had all the
ammunition he needed with the corrupt
bargain of 1824 John Quincy Adams kind
of considered himself above this kind of
mudslinging but his supporters did not
and they came out with some real gems
not only did they put out handbills with
coffins this is known as the coffin hand
bill to this day detailing
how many men had been killed by Andrew
Jackson either through execution or
duels they also accused his mother of
being a prostitute and his wife of being
a bigamist
in fact Andrew Jackson's wife died
shortly before his inauguration and he
believed to his dying day that it was
the terrible slanders about her that had
led to her untimely death another first
for the election of 1828 is Andrew
Jackson as the first candidate for the
Democratic Party this is a new party
United around Jackson in the previous
election all of the candidates had been
Republicans in one form or another but
now the Republican Party is going to
start to fade away and the Democratic
Party will come to the fore and this is
the same Democratic Party that is still
in existence in the United States today
of course its goals and ideas have
changed a great deal since the 1820s and
with this Democratic Party and even with
the supporters of John Quincy Adams what
Jackson taps into is this kind of mass
party democracy he has great party
machines working for him in eastern
cities he also really takes advantage
particularly of people on the frontier
so white people who are looking to
expand westward to kind of make it as we
would say rugged individuals people
pulling themselves up by their
bootstraps and they saw that in Andrew
Jackson because you know he had been
born fairly panelists and then by the
time he was elected president in 1828 it
become part of the frontier elite he was
now a slave holder he was one of the
guys who had made it but those on the
frontier looked to him and saw the
example of what they wanted to be
Jackson also had the advantage of being
a war hero from the Battle of New
Orleans in the war of 1812 and
throughout the 19th century those with
valorous military service will do well
in national elections and another thing
that Andrew Jackson does quite well is
anti-indian anti Native American
sentiment John Quincy Adams had
attempted to bargain in good faith to
try to hold up the side of the United
States with Native American nations
living in what was then the territorial
borders of the United States he
bargained with them as if they were
sovereign nations unto themselves Andrew
Jackson understood that white settlers
desperately wanted Indian lands and he
played to those white settlers assuring
them that he would do his utmost to
remove Native Americans from those lands
a promise that he will make good on
during his presidency so Jackson wins
the election of 1828 and immediately
it's obvious that the democracy under
Jackson is quite different from the
American system under previous
presidents at his inauguration he turns
to the crowd and boughs signaling that
he thinks of himself as being beneath
the people that he's serving he also
opens up the White House during what's
called the inaugural brawl and it's
believed that many people went into the
White House and they wrecked the China
and they destroyed the furniture and
they wouldn't leave until people told
them there was alcohol outside on the
lawn and to an earlier generation who
had been raised with this early American
aristocracy of the Adams a--'s and the
Washington's this looks to like Anarchy
they thought this was the beginning of
the French Revolution in the United
States it was not but it was the
beginning of massive party politics
political campaigns and the beginning of
a new politics in the United States that
appealed to the common man and we'll
talk more about that in the next video